fancy yourself like Batman maybe you
should try hanging upside down like
these guys or not but what if like Bruce
Wayne you spent the entire night upside
down
is it possible what would happen to your
body what is the best position to sleep
in this is what if and here's what would
happen if you slept upside down David
Blaine hung upside down for almost 60
hours in a 2008 endurance stunt 8 hours
should be no problem for the average
person then right well not exactly
it seems we're not all David Blaine take
the poor soul who got stuck upside down
in a cave in Utah he was suspended for
28 hours what happened to him he died of
asphyxiation which is the process of
being deprived of oxygen
[Music]
this is one of the risks of being upside
down for too long what if you were only
upside down for seven to eight hours to
get a full night's rest you put on your
super warm pajamas
since blankets would just slip off get
into your specially made inversion bed
strap in
drift off to sleep and then what well
there are several things that would
happen to you as you slumber with your
head directly under your feet the weight
of gravity on your organs would soon
begin to crush your delicate lungs your
body won't be able to get enough oxygen
while our bodies are great at making
sure no blood collects in our feet when
we're upright we haven't evolved the
same ability with our brains if you
slept upside down your blood would
quickly pull up in your brain which can
lead to a brain hemorrhage that would be
game over though you'd probably die from
heart failure before your brain could
hemorrhage with your head below your
heart
heart would slow down and wouldn't be
able to effectively pump all the
incoming blood your blood pressure would
become almost impossible to maintain and
cause the failure of essential functions
so long sweet dreams it's pretty clear
that we're not meant to be upside down
for long periods of time but what about
for a reduced amount inversion therapy
is the practice of being upside down for
short stints of time and that's short as
in 30 seconds to two minutes this has
multiple health benefits it helps with
blood circulation and can lower your
resting heart rate it's also amazing on
your back by increasing spinal cord
flexibility and maintaining the natural
curve of your neck if you have a robust
inversion practice you could eventually
hang upside down for 20 minutes safely
but not all night if we can't catch a
few Z's this way why can other mammals
simply put their bodies are built for it
the most famous inverted sleeper the bat
involved the ability to sleep upside
down because it makes them less visible
to predators they also don't face the
same issues that humans do since gravity
doesn't affect their circulation if
snoozing upside down is out what is the
best position it really depends on your
body while sleeping on your back is
generally considered the best because it
puts your spine in a neutral position
it's not good for people who suffer from
sleep apnea
we sleep for about one third of our
lives and it's an important factor in
our overall health
it's believed sleep helps with stress
management metabolism brain function and
mood and I don't know about you but I
feel pretty awful when I don't get
enough of it while sleep is still
somewhat a mystery one thing we know
sleep does is increase plasticity
plasticity is the brain's ability to
reorganize itself and is vitally
important for memory and learning so
what would happen if you just stopped
sleeping well that's a story for another
what if